foreign
[Music]
hey guys for all your CBD needs this is
uh my favorite right here CBD Spectrum
you go to
purespectrumcbd.com and you type in the
code congrats you get 15 off pure
Spectrum all the all the stuff and the
and the the gummies are I like the
gummies and the droppers it's good it
keeps my anxiety at Bay you know I like
this stuff
um pure Spectrum
gummies and I eat them and also they
taste really good uh but yeah go to go
to go ahead and do that and um 15 off
pure spectrum of all this stuff uh and
without further Ado welcome to another
episode of congratulations
[Music]
I wish sour these are not sour but I
wish
sour gummies were the best thing on
Earth for you because they're so good
dude I love Sour Patch Kids I love sour
watermelons I love sour Peaches I love
sour all of this
bleep that out
um but I love them all man and my mom my
mommy always gets me sour uh hearts for
Valentine's Day because she loves me and
that's beautiful
um but I love shower stuff and that's it
so what are you gonna do huh
um chrisley.com for uh your tour
um I mean uh all the Canada I'm in
Nashville I'm in Tucson
christalia.com I'm in a bunch of all of
the different cities man it's crazy dude
and I'm adding more we're adding more
for the end of December but we got
um Cincinnati and Columbus Boise Salt
Lake City uh Tucson I said that already
Colorado Springs Pueblo Colorado for
some reason Charlotte Knoxville
Little Rock Arkansas for some reason and
then a bunch of Canadian dates Detroit
Cleveland Fort Myers for some reason in
Orlando Florida dude
um yeah man that's what's up I got my
nice you know what I started doing
lately actually is dressing nicer during
the day and I've been feeling a little
bit better dude and not today but other
days
I've been feeling a little bit better
because here's the deal look I I got
nice clothes look it's no it's no secret
that I I have nice clothes there's no
secret that I've got a lot of nice
clothes come on
and I always save them for night time
because I'm like nighttime The Freaks
Come Out at Night the freaks come out at
night right and I hope we don't get
copyright strict because of how good
that was
but
um you know I'm good I'm really nice
with it
when I put my stuff on because I'm not
the guy who says hey check out these
cool clothes on me
I'm thinking here's me in these clothes
right these threads are lucky
um but yeah the show you know
the shirt's carefully draped over my
shoulders and all that stuff and it's
nice
tight where it needs to be forgiving
where it needs to be but yeah so I'm
doing it at night and then I realized
dude your boy's got a budget look it's
no surprise though your boy has a lot of
nice clothes why doesn't he wear because
sometimes they don't wear the clothes
that are nice in the day are you like me
do you not sometimes we're close that
are nice in the day because you don't
want to have to wash them and then what
if you need them for the night time but
it's like dude if you have enough nice
closes then all you got to do is just
wear nice clothes all the time and yeah
maybe you don't get to wear this nice
you know
thing at night but it's okay dude so I'm
just a little bit nicer in the daytime
also I don't know if this is a stage
shirt whatever dude it's all really
important stuff but
um anyway I'm having a good time in life
and I'm feeling good I'll tell you what
man some days uh when I put my phone
away and I go out and I live life my my
my uh my my you ever do that you ever
lived like the 90s because when I was in
rehab I didn't have my phone and
sometimes I you know like if I'm on the
road I have the flip phone and sometimes
I just I'll leave my phone in the car
when I do that my my my
because zoning in on your phone you're
probably not realize you're doing it
you're probably doing it right now right
you look at what you're looking at right
you're on you listen to my podcast on
your phone and you're also checking
Instagram or Tick Tock what are you
doing dude
we don't want to be living that life you
want to live that my my life right
so I put my phone
uh away a little bit and it was just
nice dude it was nice I feel the urge to
go check it but it's nice right it's
addiction but it's nice did I want to
check it yes did I get the hankering yes
did I avoid it sometimes that I check it
sometimes did I give in to the hankering
yes sometimes all the time no when I
didn't I felt better I felt a little bit
of anxiety but that's where the CBD
comes in pure spectrumcbd.com there we
go congrats
um yeah I went to the park and I went
with uh Calvin and a friend and it was
just my my
it was so cute and he met little boy
there and I'm at the dad and we had a
good time just playing around in my son
uh walked up to the boy and he he goes
like this
right in his face like when I say say hi
to my eyes when I say hey hey Calvin say
hi Calvin will just walk up to someone's
face like like this like he wants to
start a fight
like in his in his face just hi
and uh
and he says to the boy what you doing
tonight in the meantime it's it's like
four it's like 3 30. it says to the boy
what's he doing tonight that's his thing
now it's what you doing tonight don't
know where he heard it it's like he was
watching like Night at the Roxbury or
something
but he's just what you doing tonight
and he always walks around what you
doing tonight and it's hilarious and so
cute and so I was at the park and it was
really nice man
I was at the park and the dad was at the
park and we started talking a little bit
you know
the other kid was three and Calvin took
his face in his hand his his face in the
boy's hands and he says one over one is
want to roll around and the boy's like
okay and they just were rolling around
it's beautiful to see uh the
three-year-olds like do the socializing
and stuff because it's not it's not you
know they it was that that switch flips
boom
they're a person right like as soon as
uh as soon as will I didn't know I was
gonna call him Willy my nilly but I was
like is that a little bit but it's not
though as soon as Willy came out William
Billy boy I don't know what we're
calling him yet but
um Calvin all of a sudden he goes
and becomes an older brother and so now
he starts looking like he came down in a
suit the other day not really but you
know
um
Yeah man so Calvin's getting older we're
all getting older and life isn't forever
but life rips and that's the motto and
you either grow or die don't you
we got a lot of mottos but that's it
dude life's about motto is kind of is
what I'm saying by the way it's hot
it's hot as all get out in this little
room right now so I'm telling you right
now if you see a cut even the patreon
version it's because I gotta go get some
air okay
[Music]
we got rid of Calvin's nap
and uh because a pediatrician came over
and she was just like uh you know what
if he's just not doing it just go ahead
go ahead
and we're like all right
so he's been extra tired coming like
eight o'clock
but fighting it you know he'll be like
this from for on
and you're just like Calvin you get
tired and he's like this no and you're
like don't need to be think about it and
right and so that probably means if
you're snapping like that you're tired
but you don't know about life yet like
that right
you're tired and he's like no I know
that's big giant Pac-Man
to doing tonight
and um so I say to him uh
all right well you let me know when
you're tired okay
he's obsessed with when I put him to bed
and I'm not gonna talk about my kid the
whole time
I know the audience is split I want to
talk about my kid and when I don't talk
about my kid some people love it extra
and some people are like dude stick to
the silly goose times and I'm like why
can't it be both but also
you know
but uh he's obsessed with leaving the
door little open for some reason my son
gets locked boy I see a lot of me and
I'm right he gets up he gets locked in
sometimes like we started leaving the
door open for the bedtime and now we're
just like it's the door will open door
will open we'll put him in bed he says
open I'm like Kevin I always leave the
door a little open okay that what you
doing tonight don't wanna open
and then I'm like he's like where are
you gonna go and I'm like downstairs he
says no stay up here and then rolls over
like like such a dick you know no stay
up here I want you to stay up here okay
I'll do it
and then I go and I stay up here for a
little bit and then I step down but
um he's been getting so tired lately
because he's been you know skipping his
nap and dude he was like Holding On by a
thread
it was like 8 10 and he was just holding
his sleep sack just ready holding his
sleep sack just ready but fighting and I
said buddy you doing okay and we were
downstairs not even close to his room
and he just says yeah I'm okay and then
he immediately snaps and starts bawling
and collapses into my arm and says if
the door it'll open dude it was so funny
and so cute
good from downstairs
from long just leave that door little
open just crying and I was like okay
bloody you want to go upstairs he says
yeah don't let him open
dude kids are so funny
they're so funny
they're just so funny
is the pool tooting he says when the
bubbles come out of the Jet and I'm like
if you say so the other day he was
looking at Kristen and he says can I see
your tongue and she stuck it out she
says sure she stuck it out and he looks
at her he says what you doing tonight
[Laughter]
play a player he's just a player player
dude Kevin needs a [__] pinky ring
can I see your tongue yeah sure what you
doing tonight oh he's just a playing a
player
play a player dude that my son walked
away like did he the pimp struck him
with like this look with his hand out
like he's swimming and [__] when he
walks and holding his sleep sack like a
cane he's just a playing a player
my son is a month of way from saying to
someone at the grocery store what that
mouth do swear to god dude I'm just uh
playing up looking at the [__]
coconuts in the aisle or whatever
I'm just a player player
um but anyway dude
with a double open
um
bro I was at this uh I was at the uh
this coffee shop at parking I do I go to
the coffee shop at Park
fully
Park parking is fully open which is like
we're in La that never happens it's just
open
like there should be a lady with an
apron on singing the hills are alive in
this parking lot it's open to [__]
and uh
I park you know where I park wherever
you know why because it's open
right
I don't even go like this a little bit
I just drive in park like I'm in a
[__]
you know Ben Affleck movie like the guy
who gets the spot and you're like that's
not like how it is though but it was
is it all right I'm I'm in Gili right
now so a park
two empty spots next to me
I park
right away
into the spot to my left now that's a
little Annoying why because like I said
the parking lot was open anyone support
right next to me not only next to me but
where I gotta get out oh
hey dingbat
Park a space away so I'm like all right
fine [__] it
I get out I walk to the
coffee shop
I get in the coffee shop
and that guy gets out of his car walks
in the coffee shop
I order my coffee and then that guy
orders his coffee
and then that guy picks up his phone
and he says yeah what is it okay yeah
yeah okay yeah okay well there's it yeah
okay
and then he looks at me and he says uh
guy asks you to move your car
and I go
huh he says telling you to move your car
and I said
what what hey what phone call are you
getting he's pointing to his thing
saying guy asking you to move in your
car and I say your friend what are you
and he just goes like this go out there
already I'm pissed but also maybe
there's a good explanation also I'm
curious as [__]
you know what I mean this is like one
bad guy into the video game Silent Hill
I'm like all right I think maybe I'm
into this
I go there's another guy
on the other side of my car
parked
and he's too close to my car
and he can't get out
and he says to me
hi uh can you move your car
hey
are you listening guys
step one I park in an open field step
two guy parks next to me hard for me to
get out step three a guy parks next to
me on the other side he can't get out
step four I get called to move my car
hey are you guys listening
so I say
you want me to move my car
right back
nobody was there
and these two Armenian dudes are just
like because also look I love Armenians
you know but you guys are ready
you guys are ready I've never seen a
race more disres more ready to be
disrespected than a [__]
Armenian guy dude
like Armenians are the number one men
and women
you could just be like wow look at that
guy's got a bunch of flowers he's like
hey hey you don't say flowers around me
[Laughter]
you say what
get this get specific when you're
talking about them bro
what kind you know are they roses are
they daffodils I don't know man they
couldn't be [__] bird of paradise you
just say flowers you disrespecting me
like I might not know what type what
type they are dog
and I'm just like I swear to God
and then the chick is in the background
like he said flowers
and you're just like oh what's happening
with two phones and [__]
and so um so I'm like you want me to
move my car and he says yeah
but he's like here's the thing he says
yeah in such a way that it might be
foreign enough to wear oh [__] now I
can't really be that mad right because I
don't know if he's just got the language
barrier thing that makes him seem like a
dick when he really wishes he could be a
nice guy because let's put yourself in
uh
Spain
put yourself in Spain you don't know
Spanish unless you do but you know put
yourself in nobody who listens to this
podcast knows Japanese put yourself in
Japan right you don't know Japanese you
know a little bit of Japanese and then
some guy's in the way and you're trying
to get into the bathroom
you don't know Japanese
right so you might be like uh uh
you might not move right you might just
be like
ah
and then the guy's like
he may not know all the words ago
so you're like all right forgiving so
I'm like maybe he's not being a dick I
can't really if he was an american guy
that just was born here that had no
accident accent accident accident had no
accent and he was just like hey move
your car I would be like yo bro hey
you're and here's the the other thing
too is the paint on my car really hard
to duplicate it's Matt
so I don't want him to dig it out [__]
so I'm like maybe it's not worth it so I
say
you know what okay I'll move my car I
move my car a little bit and I move it
back so he can get out and he says thank
you I'm like Alicia says thank you so I
walk back in and I say to the guy hey
was that guy your friend and he says yes
thanks
all good
all good it was cool it was fine
it was good you know
I'm glad we got through that all three
of us
hey hey
don't hey be more specific when you're
talking about flowers
what kind sunflower or what
kind bougainvillas or what
a a lily or what what is it the kind
where you blow and all those [__]
[__] things come up be specific dog
um second episode in a row I said
bougainvilleas
um
all good Bing whoops sorry uh hit I
haven't get rid of
um so anyway but I guess it's got good
aim I'm Gambit with the [__] water
TOPS oh so uh
and then I'm in the [__] coffee shop
just not I'm thinking of it
and this guy
because when I pulled into the coffee
shop there was a guy that was kind of
blocking the thing the the the entrance
to the actual parking lot a lot of
parking lot stories and I go but I
always try to do the quick one
Bank bank because the second you go bang
you're a dick
and it depends on what the person's
doing you can do it back if they're
being
an ignoramus or if they're trying to be
a dick you could just
bang until they move
so
I go time and he moves all good great I
was nice he was nice loved the dude God
after I all that [__] happened the guy
that guy was took another parking space
right neither here nor there but he was
in the parking he was in the coffee
place and he says
uh dude
bucket list and I said huh and he says
Chris I was in christalia's way
and I'm like oh yeah it's all good that
was you in that car and he says yup
crazy and I said yeah well you know it's
all good man we got through it he says
yup do you have a dentist
and I said uh
yeah but I haven't I haven't been in a
while yeah
aren't you coming to me
and I was like you're a dentist and he
said yeah
and I said uh
you know
okay
but
you know what I was thinking
I'll never see this guy after this you
know
you know what I'm saying
imagine when somebody says you know the
feeling you get when you when you say
I'm an adult I'm 43. some of you guys
are 43. some of you guys are 35 some of
you guys are 50 right
imagine somebody says hey
come to my birthday party on Friday
night
what do you think you think oh uh I want
to be home but maybe I can but I kind of
don't want to but maybe I should
and a party is the most fun thing you
can do
dental work hey guy
go away
dental work is the worst thing to do
and this guy's like hey
let me drill into your teeth for a
little bit stranger
so I'm like okay
because you don't just
I gotta get to a position I could have
been
this is the thing man my wife's always
like you got to be nicer to people and I
she's right so but it's like that kind
of means lying sometimes
so I'm just like all right yeah he says
can I get your number I'll just text you
with my assistant and we'll set
something up and I say
555 you know like we're not like we're
in a junk movie but that's the fake
number thing five yeah sure here we go
here's my number I leave the this is
awesome dude set you up I leave I get a
group text let me just even I don't even
know if I can find it but I get a group
text
this was a while ago only Pastor these
texts that I have Simon racks BLB
famous comedians
Bert Kreischer famous
Charles Barkley
Sammy Davis Jr
Theo
um
I can't
hear
but the Rock and Kevin Hart what the
[__]
um
I should read it to you guys though hold
on I don't even know if it's I honestly
didn't even read it I'll read for the
first time here oh CVS [__] you know
hey CBS
chill dude I'll I'll be there you know
here we go
I love it it says maybe and then the
dentist's office
how they know
hi Chris please meet my office manager
at
the place
hey and then to the office manager can
you work Chris into our schedule for a
comp oh compt
[Music]
for a compt
exam X-rays and teeth whitening and or
cleaning please
Yahoo dude what the [__]
I didn't even read it dude you want to
[__] work me in
[Music]
what why is it here
you want to work me in dude
sensational
dude
when they call my name
[__] man I should have hit him up
damn that's
wow [__] missed it he said Thursday or
Friday well didn't even ghosted my new
dentist
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh well you know what you win some you
lose some I literally didn't even read
it until right now wow dude what a
surprise puppy surprise
um
ah
sometimes you meet a dentist and you
[__] don't do this [__] and you
should have done the [__] you know
but not just like life
uh
Coachella happened shouldn't have
happened huh
Coachella is just
Jeff Bezos went you know
so
that's that's there you go
God
imagine you're at Coachella
and you're hanging out and you're
watching like either Frank Ocean or some
[__] Death Cab for Cuties and you're
just like
rolling your ass off and you turn to
your right and no and you hear and and
in the in the background
like you hear in the it very very very
very very quietly you hear
and you turn and it's [__] Jeff Bezos
and you say are you Jeff Bezos
hell yes
dude imagine
oh [__]
that's to remind me to do a check-in
with my wife recovery
um but yeah I also get another timer
also at seven because sometimes I forget
at five and I'm doing something else and
I gotta call my wife and then if I can
get a chicken with my mind to make sure
that I'm not path of recovery all good
that's very important all good
struggling with the 12 Steps right now
but it's all good right because I don't
really [__] know if I believe in God
and God's wrong you know change your
higher power could be anything okay so
good
foreign
what's my higher power my friends my
family or just the people in the group
themselves or like whatever but it's all
good so
um yeah anyway Coachella and you see
Jeff Bezos and it's just like man I
don't know man maybe I should just bite
the bullet and go to [__] Coachella
week two just happened but
um
bass I was killing it oh dude here's
something on that I just can click on
Dylan Mulvaney Hot Shots
you know
I made a thing about I was talking about
Dylan Mulvaney and I posted a clip on it
on Instagram
dude and I gotta tell you I think
ins I think that they were
okay I'm not gonna lie if I squint right
there
he looks all right
but she looks alright sorry
um I didn't mean that as a joke uh but
oh that was
um oh my god
um okay so anyway
live your life for real
um but I posted a clip which I had
nothing negative
about Trent t-r-a-n-s
right I just said
uh he looked sorry [__]
she looks crazy
right
I said Dylan
is crazy not because Dylan's trans
because look at him right
you can tell when someone's Crazy by
looking at them a lot of the time right
and and like let's just let's not mince
words here when someone's crazy
you know you know because you know why
look at their eyes
you know
like I've had I've had beef I've had
public beef with people look at it who
might be right about that situation you
know what I'm saying look at their eyes
and then look at my face which is you
know Silly Goose time
uh
so
I said this thing about it
about the thing about how the Bud Light
thing was and I was like look you know
because and I said and Tran real trans
people joke obviously I was like real
trans people are like here we go again
some crazy [__] speaking for us
meeting Dylan and people just I think
that they might be suppressed in a video
because I got a lot of comments under it
but not a lot of views
yeah
but anyway people were like oh really so
you can tell when someone's crazy just
by looking at them huh nice superpower
you got and it's like yeah yeah yes it's
funny when somebody says something like
that you go back on your heels but then
you're like wait a minute yeah dude you
know
like when you see somebody on the side
of the street and they're just like ah
Jesus is not enough Jesus Jesus is not
enough oh that person's crazy dude I was
in a coffee shop once got walked in and
screamed science is everywhere and
walked out hey guess what he's not a
scientist
and I'm not saying t-r-a-n-s and I said
that in case they do do the you know
what I'm saying
they're not you know do they I don't
even care enough you be you I don't care
enough
I don't care enough men
I'm a woman
a straight one
I'll suck all sorts of [__]
but man they you know these people were
and then some trans people were like oh
you know what dude he's right Chris is
right and then other people were like
there's one that was just like you know
you can't speak for the trans Community
I love you though I like not mean like I
mean not like they're a fan of mine but
like I send you love and it's just like
oh
sending you love and like you know don't
hey how about this don't ever send me
you can send me love don't ever send me
light
don't ever don't ever do the loving
light dude you get to the light I go nah
dude you stop it love
you give me loving cash
you can give me a Little Love in Hip Hop
but dude you you you go to light I'm out
I don't need light dude
the snake the rat the cat the dog how
you gonna see him when you're living in
the fall the fog the fog living in the
fog the fog dude when I was [__] 19
just in my Suburban the snake the red
the cat the dog how you gonna see him
when you're living in the [__] the [__]
the [__] [__] yeah dude
nobody know like I know the black albino
coming through like a rhino DMX rest in
peace dude [__] yeah man DMX is the
illest so was so um
yeah dude
how about this guy gets high on 40 this
guy
drank 40 packets of instant coffee at
once
okay
the police arrested me from trespassing
and they lost you to sell for 30 days
I drink a month for the coffee today he
told me he drank 40 days worth of
instant coffee he's been saving up the
whole time he was in jail seems pretty
hyper
can I have a soup try to sleep it off
oh my how are you feeling more you know
I'm just gonna stay away from the
Colombian horse I can't handle coffee
apparently not hey I can handle the
crystal meth stop cooking the
coffee's done I do my coffee and I'm
cracking anyone would think he's highly
on some illegal drugs but I confirmed
that he was in the Henderson jail he
really is just high on god wow holy [__]
I gotta do that that looks like a
[__] massively good time
and how sore is he going to be the next
day just so like La just locked up
sleeping I don't mean in jail a lot his
body just locked the [__]
and then the next day you just oh his
voice is just so gone
that's hilarious
I gotta watch it again
for 30 days
the Joker
he told me he drank 40 days worth of
instant coffee he's been saving up dude
he's facing a wall that's amazing
the cop is tricky he says Hey can I have
some
dude this guy's the best he's like the
worst Batman villain [__] coffee head
caffeine brain
doctor doctor [__]
Sanka I don't give a [__] about that
joke
um
laughs
[__] Dr Sanka [__] [__] who
cares dude whatever man Tucker Carlson
fired
part well mutually agreed to part ways
yeah that's like saying I've mutually
agreed agreed to be cut out of [__]
Army of the Dead
um
so uh Taco Carlson and Fox News have
agreed to part ways the network said
Monday the news came less than an hour
before CNN announced that the split with
long time
oh yeah yeah because he him too Don
Lemon and bro what a news
what a media shake-up man
what the [__] is the world gonna be like
in two weeks
what if this was the end of the world
because Don Lemon and Tucker Carlson
Mr Carlson was program last night they
were apparently promoting his show
um
the whole time
and then one day it was just like it's
gone so I don't know if something
happened
huh Carlson I just can't wait to see
what these right wing dudes come up with
a as a you know
as of oh you know really what you know
that kind of thing you know really what
happened right what well
he spoke on saving the children and
they agreed and then it got him into
that's how they always start that's how
that's how [__] starts that's how you
get people on your side save the
children right yeah yeah okay good let's
go throw ourselves into a volcano whoa
what we want to save the children don't
you yeah of course they're they're
children okay then jump in all right
um
say the children yeah yeah you want to
say the children of course I do Biden's
a lizard right
um
I don't I don't know I mean he looks
well you want to save the children you
don't want to say the children no I do
mine's a lizard and save children
okay sure yeah
um
Carlson exit comes less than a week
after the Fox News agreed to pay
787.5 million to Dominion voting systems
to settle the election software
companies defamation claim oh okay wow
wow
oh [__] they got
oh I wonder if that's why they fired him
then
or mutually split sorry
um
and Don lemon's gone huh Don Lemon was
pissed you can tell Don Lemon gets
so
[__] mad
you can just tell
like you'd be playing Call of Duty and
then you'd be like God that guy's mad
and cut to Don Lemon just like
um
yeah dude wow that's that's pretty wild
um what a media shake-up is what I like
to call I like to call it a media
shake-up because it is frankly
um
what is this a video of a guy a video of
a guy confronting wow
oh look at this smile the guy's got
I don't care man
he says I appreciate them
United States to everything else in this
world
they're in a wine shop you know
oh wow called him son good job
whoa dude why did it stop there
wow what alone that guy was
just you are the worst human being
it's a smile this is a scene from smile
wow
he got his space too dude
that's crazy
you are
the worst human being
why did he sound like uh the South Park
hey what was the big gay owl is that him
who's that guy yeah
this guy's Chad gbt
hey can you give me a riddle
sure here's a riddle for you this is
John gbd I am always hungry I must
always be fed
the finger I touch will soon turn red
what am I guy says are you fire
no I am not fire can you guess the
answer to the riddle I provided I don't
know
the answer to the riddle is fire
is always hungry and needs to be fed
with fuel if you touch a finger to flame
it will turn red from the Heat
so dumb the simplest dumbest thing
no
oh what are you fire
that's like I'm his silly rabbit is that
what he calls you now
I'm Mr Sterling everything
um
oh the [__]
airplane shut up
[Music]
oh they're fighting in there
oh [__]
no
you're gonna ruin our trip to trash down
wow said nothing please oh boy
I love how Ricky Ricardo's there Ricky
Ricardo come down come down
who cares it's a good time to stop
smoking
got kids here shut up
restaurants in Orlando let's go oh
that's weird they're going to Orlando
um
even if they weren't going to Orlando
they had to fly to Orlando after that
and be like this is where you belong
um
that's crazy
man this [__] is crazy what's going on
with um
what's his name Majors uh Jonathan
Majors the the Marvel dude Dr Kang or
whatever the [__] guys got apparently he
this is it man everyone jump [__] ship
he got arrested for apparently
I don't know how rough he got I don't
I'm not I don't know because I don't
believe [__] that's reported anyway but
he hit or so they clamped so you'll
claim if they hit his girl friend and
then got arrested and then she was like
oh I didn't mean to do that and then
just [__] he was on a uh uh
commercial for the Army they yanked it
he was going to be part of the new
baseball team's [__] uh season
promotion that yanked it they took him
out of a movie that somebody was who's
supposed to play some guy they ganked it
they [__] now Marvel is like what do
we do bro this guy you we don't know
what happened man we don't know what
happened now obviously I got a [__] a
bone to pick with this [__] because we
don't know what happened stop in [__]
three hours just being like all right
dude done this guy we don't know what
[__] happened there's crazy people on
all sides we don't know what happened
it's so insane and then here's the other
thing dude hey The Flash
this guy Ezra has been accused of
all of it
you know it's like dude when they if
they ever charge this dude they're gonna
be like all right well so what are you
talking about the guy's gonna be like
bet all the stuff you can do
that's not good
and this guy's The Flash you know why
dude they already finished it they put
too much money into it they put too much
they put too much um he's already in too
many DC things
and also
he does he's non-binary that's why I
said it oh shitty City
they don't you know what I mean
[Applause]
right he's doing a little crazy quirky
stuff so people are like oh [__] well
we'll see
we'll see but when it when [__]
Jonathan majors
you know why because my wife a week
before that [__] happened my wife was
like man this guy Jonathan Majors is
[__] sexy and I was like who's that
and I look at him and I'm like yeah he
you know he's [__] He's Got That Beef
right
on the Army commercial he's just like yo
join the Army because you know why I was
in the Army and we shoot [__]
and I'm like I get it Kristen I get it
dude
and then a week later they go yank yank
and I'm just like but the Flash
it only met money only mattered they
think this it just sucks man who knows
what happened who knows what happened
who knows
so it's so crazy bro it sucks it sucks
so that's what that you know so that's
where we're at
um
yeah
imagine all the Marvel uh guys all had
podcasts too and they were just like
talking about it making it worse
foreign
you guys uh yeah so that's what's up but
so what else so so anyway so what else
is going on we got um
speaking of [__] great great times
no uh I
forgot to mention we got this [__]
grow or die merch dude
it's killer it's beautiful it's out
there and it's live chrislea.com
um we got it and it's [__] so cool
it's a it's it's got that grower die
like the 80s skater die [__] with the
flower wilting like is the flower alive
or not dude
and then we got the one plastic over the
back like that like oops off the
shoulders like really nice like it
starts with the G over here and just
Whoopsie Daisy and all over the back
right just kind of cascading over the
back dude I'm telling you right now I
make the sickest merch
period when it comes to Comedy
said it and forget it like Ron Popeil
dude
wow how do I even know that that guy's
name is Ron Popeil worst name alive
worst name in the history of man
including all the names that were in the
1200s and [__]
Ron
Popeil
[Laughter]
anyway dude grow or die christy.com Ron
is the I thought Keith and Ken were bad
names Ron goes like this hey Keith Ken
excuse me I'm here dude Ron
wow wow dude I forgot about the name Ron
until now that's the worst [__] name
I've ever heard and then also his last
name is
Popeil
you know what it sounds like an 80s
[__] Dodger Ron Popeil takes the bat
Ron popeils at the plate
surely needing at least a double to run
into
players to get two runs Howard Johnson
is on third begging to cross the blade
Ron Paul Beal who is
coming from the infomercial world
where is coin phrases set it and forget
it talking about drying beef or also
cooking salmon swinging a Miss strike
one
sup with my eye
remember when Vin Scully tweeted a
picture of his eye and then died
um
so disgraceful how I just said that all
good
it's a crazy world out there
it is a crazy crazy world out there
um
[__] there was something I just wanted
to talk about and I just can't remember
what the [__] it was dude
and I can't remember
great
[__] can't remember William's doing
well
he's good he won't stop eating bro he he
won't stop eating
you're supposed to get your birth weight
so what happens is you're born
let's say you're seven two which is what
William was
and then
in the next few days you lose a bunch of
weight because that's all that birth
[__]
that just goes away
and then in two weeks you're supposed to
reach back to your birth weight
five days in
William was seven nine
just a tubby you know and that's great
because Calvin would not eat he still
doesn't
like I thought I thought he was doing
well and he is doing well like verbally
this dude is Vince Vaughn verbally my
son is just like like he's saying
actually and [__] and the word available
I swear to God he said the word
available the other day my mom came over
and she was like what toys you want to
play with and my son said let's see
what's available and I was just like
okay he's three right
so he's got the Gift of Gab you know
what I mean of course
look where he comes from but
you know I thought he was like tall and
maybe dude he was with that other kid in
the park I was talking about earlier on
and my gosh man I mean he that kid was
like a a monster compared to him and he
was the same age and but you know my son
was talking circles around him so
is what it is right
see what else we got here I want to
actually uh I'm some dripping sweat but
we'll ride this out I'm dripping sweat
but we'll ride it out and it's all good
um
we can do uh
some uh I wanted to do these deserved
scales and then also
some tenders have poor sea legs
my heels about chained up I mean what
kind of kinky [__] is this
this is the most foreign this is the
most Asian thing I've ever seen
the only thing more Asian about this
would be if they were at Kmart
so many Asians at Kmart lately that's
all I'm saying
um oh she kind of did it
does she fall in and then he's trying to
help
this is the most deserve it look at the
guy trying to help because he wants to
[__] her you know what I mean I'm just
good I'm Just a Good Samaritan
get a job though
what what is this like why are there
planks of
oh wow
wow I mean dude now the other way she's
hanging well she can't do this
I mean grow an athletic bone for [__]
sake you know
have you worked out a day in your life
am I wrong for this why is she Shackled
to the [__] rope
that's it and now the dude's going wow
ain't that a metaphor for life
dude if I'm there oh there we go I'm
cutting the Rope if I'm there
the worst game show
oh he's down he bounced fend for
yourself [__] that's what he does
oh now he's in I mean just jump in it's
a [__] [__] it's Shin deep
why are they on there
that's how you'd have to get somewhere
in a horror movie where everyone is
there to kill you and then the planks
come in
wow dude love it
they deserve they just honestly deserve
to get way way more wet than that
um
there we go
oh wow these things are so these things
are if you don't look at what are they
called what are these things called the
jet
feet jet that shoot you up on the lake
I know I'm talking about the one with
the reporter you have that link with the
reporter we played that on this thing
find that and send it to me but dude
that where you jet up off of the C and
and you're in the air those things are
not ready okay I'll take it right now
hey don't do those they're not ready all
right that's the [__] honestly you
know what that is that's the Friendster
version of what really is supposed to
take off the Myspace right friendship
was like cool but then they realized oh
wait my space is way better Myspace got
all the [__] cash and the money that
this is the Friendster [__] the Myspace
is when they do it air when they do it
with air off over the ground you don't
need to [__] make the one with the
tube over the am I making any sense here
so
here we go
oh wow she's trying to dance or he's
trying to dance he's killing it oh dude
this is gonna end it that's really cool
looking
it did so Jamaican the whole thing I
love it
um do you have that that clip or no yeah
under it wow oh watch out bumbaclot
that's what he said this is my favorite
we've watched this before early on in
the podcast San Diego so good I love
that this happened to this guy good
morning everybody I'm hanging out with
my friend John Fox 5 Morning News starts
look over there and it starts right now
laughs
this might have invented the deserved
scale and dude the little uh after and
it starts right now is it's
flamingly funny do you understand
hold on let's do it and it starts right
this is the ultimate pendulum swing
so [__] how he's looking at this so
[__] oh he's holding it like this dude
the whole thing about it Fox 5 News
just like so ready and then good morning
everybody I'm hanging out with my friend
John Fox 5 Morning News starts look over
there and it starts right now dude the
[__] oh
oh
that's it when I see if I were there
live in that studio and that happened I
don't even laugh I just go
piss immediately down my leg and also
[__] even if I even if I just went that
is the funniest thing to ever happen
known to man
and it starts like that uh
I mean that was just great could it have
happened to a [__] more deserving
person no the shiniest shortest guy you
know
let's do another deserved scale
here we go here we go what the big ass
[__] thing in the skate park wow let
go buddy let go let dum dum
I mean why is I did oh won't stop
let go bro what is it about that where
you don't let go he's on one of those
[__] dorky ass things that only old
white guys or rappers have what are
those [__] things called
they're called like uh a dinosaur name
or something or
it's not a T-Rex you know what I'm
talking about though that they're called
T-Rexes
yeah yeah oh this is not that
anything with three wheels an old white
guy or only a rapper has that comes off
dude what they're called slingshot these
are yeah maybe something like that
dude you gotta be [__] straight up
like for real you gotta look like the
guy who played the old flash in the 90s
TV show or Lil Durk to have one of these
um
anyway
that's great wow he deserved it because
just let go dude let go
like eventually if you don't let go the
Rhythm Is Gonna Get You
uh the Rhythm Is Gonna Get You The
Rhythm is gonna catch ya
uh while I fail trying this trick wow
oh fell for so long oh when people
bro you know what I realized is the best
deserved scale when the thing happens
and that's not it
then there's more [__] that happens well
you think he's just gonna fall and then
a bunch of [__] coffee grinds falls
on him or some [__] or the potted plant
s
he fell then fell again then the thing
fell
that honestly that's a 10. that's that
top note that is in that is a 10
deserves kit
didn't get hurt but has a bunch of [__]
in his eyes you know like that is the
best wow
that's so good and I love that he's
British and it happened all right that's
good you guys thank you for listening
thank you for watching I appreciate you
it's hot and all get out I gotta take I
gotta [__] go I gotta go it's too hot
disgusting vomited in my mouth uh go to
purespectrumcbd.com and type in the code
congrats to get your CBD shits the
gummies I like and also the the [__]
dropper I use those are really good for
uh keeping me you know at Bay and then
um go to chrisley.com for my tour dates
coming up on some Tucson [__] and uh
Ohio anyway dude and that new grower die
merch killing it out there chrisley.com
go get it and uh it's the best merch in
the game appreciate you guys that's it
for the episode on YouTube if you want
to check the uh rest of the episode The
uncut episode the extended episode with
no ads no nothing go to uh patreon.com
Chris Delia for six bucks only you can
get all of the rest of the also you can
get always the episode of you can get
the hi buddy
you wanna come in come on in you get the
rest of the patreon episode and uh you
can also get the we do one episode an
extra a month and you can uh keep
showing yeah you can go sorry my son is
being so cute right now come over here
buddy
um you can get the rest of the episode
look at these little top his little head
you can get the rest of the uh stuff on
patreon uh you have an episode of hey
come here give an episode a month an
extra episode a month
hey bud say hi
say hi
all right thanks thanks for watching
[Music]
thank you